I would say that last year their primary
interest was in crypto equities publicly
traded crypto stocks uh coinbase
silvergate Riot Etc there's still some
interest there but we're seeing a lot
more interest in directly accessing
Bitcoin ethereum and large cap assets uh
maybe to some extent people are moving
not away from but beyond Venture Capital
you know the initial steps into crypto
for a lot of institutions were Venture
Capital exposures and that will continue
to be a very important part of what they
do but we're seeing them wanting to add
on Direct exposure to bitcoin and
ethereum the other thing that may not be
obvious to the outside world is
all right guys bang bang I've got Matt
here with me Matt I thought a great
place to start this conversation is why
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency seem to be
doing so well to start 2023. it feels
like there's a lot of chaos and
uncertainty in the traditional Market uh
and therefore people are running towards
these assets so they're looking at them
as safe havens how are you guys looking
at kind of the really Explosive
Performance of these assets given
everything that's going on in finance
right now yeah no first it's great to be
here uh and thanks for that thanks for
that question and having me on I think
they're three primary drivers you know
the big one that people are overlooking
is that crypto is simply a cyclical
business it always has been we've had
three big up years followed by a
pullback year right 2011 to 2013 a great
time first time that Bitcoin was
available to Traders and then we reset
in 2014 because we got over our skis
right Mount gox collapsed we didn't get
a Bitcoin ETF we reset 2015 the creation
of ethereum a lot of excitement around
that three-year bull market we reset in
2018 when Regulators crack down on icos
2019 we had D5 stable coins nfts right
so the D5 boom three great salad years
then a little bit too much leverage
built up we had the FED reset and reset
so the history of crypto is like big
technological breakthrough a lot of
excitement get over our skis and reset
we're in this fourth cycle
there is a lot of excitement in crypto
right now I think you know that I think
the listeners know that we have
everything that's going on with layer
twos we have massive evolutions and
scaling and throughput lowering of costs
we have all the venture capital
investment over the last three years
coming home to roost with new
applications that people are excited
about so we're in a new bull market
cycle so regardless of what was
happening outside of crypto I think we
were due for a rally this year and I
think it will be a multiple year rally
now you take that and you sprinkle in
what's happening we have a banking
crisis showing the flaws of the
traditional system that forces people to
open up to Alternatives and what
alternative is there there's crypto we
have the expectation for interest rates
long-term falling right they were we
were expected to be about five and a
half percent at the beginning of the
year now it's four and a half percent
crypto is a long duration asset so that
directly translates into higher prices
and we have these regulatory headlines
which I think from the mainstream media
and outside of crypto people see as
negative
if you're in crypto you expected it we
knew there would be a regulatory
Crackdown and you know that regulatory
Clarity will be a good thing so like the
coinbase news I think is going to be a
long-term Catalyst for crypto so we were
already going to be at a bull market and
then you take these nice catalysts and
you have the best performing asset class
in the world this year and I think
that's where we are when you look at
these assets one of the kind of promises
of The Cypher Punk movement was these
are going to be assets outside of the
system if you then look at kind of the
institutions are coming it was no we're
going to take these assets we're going
to put it inside of the system and
actually we're going to put it in the
portfolios of every single uh
institution in the world
now it seems like maybe we're getting
some bifurcation in the way people are
looking at this right when the banking
crisis happens we see Bitcoin uh rally
some people say hey that's because
people are looking for an alternative to
that traditional system the debt limit
there was a rally when uh we kind of hit
that and it got pushed out to June and
people saying wait a minute maybe this
is going to be some sort of hedge
against uh you know a U.S potential
default but at the same time we're
seeing the regulatory Crackdown and I
think investors trying to coalesce
around assets that fall within that
regulatory regime how do you all look at
you know these assets moving forward in
the United States inside the system
outside the system and kind of how are
you positioning the business to uh to
benefit from that yeah that's a great
question
mistake people make is thinking that
it's binary right like this had to be a
totally cypher-punk alternative movement
that would rise up in a revolution and
completely replace the existing system I
think that it was never going to happen
if we were going to be you know isolated
and truly separate outside of the
traditional system we were always going
to be niche in order to grow we need
clear regulation we need institutional
investors to come into the market we
need the bulk of capital to come into
the market we need it to scale up we
think ultimately they converge now it's
important to note there's nothing about
allowing and making it comfortable for
institutions to invest into Bitcoin to
change the fact that centralized
authorities can't alter the fundamentals
of the Bitcoin ecosystem right there's
nothing really that can be done from a
regulatory perspective to fundamentally
alter the promise of how the ethereum
blockchain works and so even if it's not
this complete separate alternative you
can still make it enormous by bringing
it slightly more into the mainstream and
capture 90 of that sort of psychopunk
good Freedom aspect of it and that's how
we think of it so you know bitwise
exists to help professional investors
access the opportunities of crypto
crypto should want that because they
have a lot of money it will be supported
to the ecosystem but we're very
supportive of the underlying ethos of
crypto at the same time and we think
they can exist side by side you all are
interesting you know I've been an
investor in the business for a long time
I've watched kind of the evolution go
from kind of single asset type funds to
now public structures private structures
fund to funds single assets indexes like
you've really kind of built out an
entire ecosystem to cover this and so
what that affords you is uh kind of this
um you know bird's eye view of what
investors are actually doing given the
great performance of the asset class at
the start of this year where are
investors Capital flowing and then where
maybe inside of this ecosystem is
investor Capital flowing away from do
you see any Trends or changes there yeah
uh we we definitely do you know we have
25 uh sales people that are out knocking
on the doors of financial advisors
talking to thousands of advisors every
month so we know what they're thinking
uh I would say that last year their
primary interest was in crypto equities
publicly traded crypto stocks uh
coinbase silvergate Riot Etc there's
still some interest there but we're
seeing a lot more interest in directly
accessing Bitcoin ethereum and large cap
assets uh I think uh maybe to some
extent people are moving not away from
but beyond Venture Capital you know the
initial steps into crypto for a lot of
institutions were Venture Capital
exposures and that will continue to be
in a very important part of what they do
but we're seeing them wanting to add on
Direct exposure to bitcoin and ethereum
uh and maybe some other assets I would
say that that's that's the primary thing
we're saying the other thing that may
not be obvious to the outside world is
there's been no bear Market from our
perspective in US best professional
investor interest in crypto
platform improve roles and major
International platforms allocations by
advisors allocations by Family offices
that didn't notice that the market went
down last year it continued to move up
into the right maybe not at the speed we
saw in 2021 but still very positive
progress so that's that's really what
we're seeing why do you think that the
institutional investors uh somewhat
ignored the price drawdown is it
something where prices go down they know
buy more or there's there's something
else driving that I think that's a big
piece of it they also move extremely
slowly you know one thing I like to say
is all the short-term news in crypto is
bad it's the FTC this and SEC that and
this regulatory Crackdown and all the
long-term news is good you look where
crypto is today versus the last bear
Market cycle it's 10x on every
fundamental metric you look at and
institutions move at what we feel is
like a glacial Pace right multiple years
of doing due diligence and if you're
doing looking at this not over last year
but from here versus 2018
this Market's huge right Bitcoin was
three thousand dollars in 2018. it's
almost thirty thousand dollars today uh
you know the number of developers was in
the hundreds it's in the thousands
number of users 10x coinbase has gone
from 20 million users to 110 million
users and because they operate on this
different time scale than retail
investors the trends they're seeing are
actually positive and I think that
explains a lot of what's going on tell
me a little bit more about the Bank
crisis and we obviously saw a silver
gate kind of uh you know voluntarily
shut down they're going to liquidate
their assets we've seen uh not so
voluntary uh you know kind of failures
of Silicon Valley Bank and Signature
Bank we then kind of saw that spread
into Credit Suisse and then Deutsche
Bank and you know First Republic came
under pressure and it just became this
like widespread thing how have you seen
the conversations change with some of
the investors whether they are current
investors or potential investors given
that uh kind of development in the
traditional banking world yeah I think
what it did is it broadened the Overton
window of what people consider as
possible I think people were operating
this world where banks are fine and
they're operating their sound and we
don't need to worry about it and now
people realize that that's not the case
I think a lot of people learned a lot
about bank accounting rules about
duration mismatch and about the
potential risks there and it's really
had two impacts on the market you know
one is outside of crypto which I think
is going to continue for a long time
which is deposits have been sucked out
of Banks and put into money market funds
right that is a massive trillion dollar
plus and growing Trend inside of crypto
I think what it did is it opened
people's minds to well maybe I should
consider an alternative maybe I want a
little bit of exposure to this alternate
view this alternative view as an
insurance policy it's worth noting that
the best month in bitcoin's history was
during the Cypress Bank crisis right and
Bitcoin was founded in the global
financial crisis I don't think that's a
coincidence every time you shock the
traditional system people think there
may be more value than I thought in an
alternative system and it doesn't have
to be you don't have to view it as
crypto is going to replace traditional
Finance you just have to think I should
have some exposure to this other idea
and so I think that's the conversation
we've been having with clients what's
interesting is uh the word hedge comes
up a lot uh usually with Bitcoin but I
think now kind of a broader set of
assets and sometimes it is a chaos hedge
it is an inflation hedge it is a bank
crisis hedge it is a debt limit hedge at
the end of the day are these assets just
insurance on the existing system failing
and if the existing system doesn't fail
hey I'm glad I had it but we shouldn't
expect there to be a kind of true
long-term value or could it be a hedge
in the short term and maybe over the
long term there are other things that
make them valuable yeah I think it's a
hedge against mistakes uh broadly uh in
the short term I think that's absolutely
absolutely right and that hedge won't go
away there's always the opportunity for
mistakes central banks can make mistake
Bankers can make mistakes and so having
an alternative system is a hedge and
then of course yes there are other
applications in crypto I mean before the
banking crisis what people were talking
about was the tremendous uh development
Pace in the ethereum and Layer Two
ecosystem and all the real world
applications that can solve immediate
problems outside of Finance they were
talking about far caster and solving the
problems with social media they were
talking about Hive mapper and solving
the limitations of maps they were
talking about International payroll uh
they were talking about music nfts or
rewards programs so this you sort of get
both uh for free you get you you buy
this hedge and you get a free call
option on all the other things you can
do with decentralized platforms and
that's a pretty nice trade so I do think
you framed it correctly it's a hedge and
it has these other applications and uh
you sort of get two for one when you
think about Investors allocating to the
space A lot of times in the traditional
Financial world there's the passive
versus the active uh kind of
conversation and people come out on both
sides of that debate it's very heated at
times and I don't know if we've actually
arrived at a single answer uh to the
debate but it's fun to do on Twitter uh
inside of the Bitcoin and crypto world
uh you all are unique because you do
have some passive vehicles but also you
allow for these kind of single asset
funds so somebody could actively go and
just buy one asset first another where
do you see most of the interest and how
are rias or other institutional
investors treating this is this like a
buy it and I'm just gonna look at it
again in 10 years are they trying to
actively move around in positions on a
day-to-day or week to week basis what
are you seeing from the kind of their
actual behavior in holding these assets
yeah that's a great question uh you know
first I'll say I think everyone that's
into crypto is making an active decision
because it's outside of the traditional
Investment Portfolio so I think there's
Alpha in Al King and crypto and that
they should be you know seen as Pioneers
for an active perspective but yeah we
offer index funds as active strategies
most people just want exposure the
reason we started with index funds is
most people outside of crypto spend two
percent of their time thinking about
crypto and they're not thinking about
Bitcoin versus ethereum or ethereum
versus Cosmos or will it value accrue to
apps like uniswap or layer twos or layer
one solutions they just think hey crypto
is going to be big in five years I want
exposure so that you know the primary
allocation is the index-based allocation
but they're absolutely people who need
to operate in traditional Financial
Vehicles which is what bitwise operates
in who wanted that only on ethereum and
real world applications or they want to
look down into single assets uh and so
that's probably a minority I would say
the other thing that's really important
that these professional investors do is
they allocate but they also rebalance so
they allocate but if they have okay to
the start of 2022 and the market went
down they're going to buy more into
2023. if they allocate in 2023 and the
market is up they're probably going to
sell and rebalance their portfolio
that's the other thing that I think
separates how professional investors do
crypto versus many retail investors is
that rebalance effort so one of the
things that you and many other asset
managers in the industry have tried to
accomplish is to get a us-based uh
Bitcoin ETF approved not Futures but
actual spot Bitcoin ETF we do not have
that yet there are many other
jurisdictions around the world that do
have that asset available to them what
is your take on where we currently are
both in terms of the applications the
denials will we see one of those
approved in 2023 or how are you thinking
about a spot Bitcoin ETF in the U.S yeah
it's been more than a decade the first
spot Bitcoin application was in 2013
when Bitcoin was trading for eighty
dollars so investors could have had
exposure at that time and written it up
to 28 000 uh and that has been denied
them which I think is a travesty they've
also been forced into less secure less
safe Solutions along the way
I'm not optimistic we get to spot
Bitcoin ETF this year uh there have been
so many rejections bitwise doesn't
currently have a spot Bitcoin ETF
application on file because we think the
door is closed it's interesting to watch
the grayscale SEC lawsuit I think that
could push us down a pathway that leads
eventually to a spot Bitcoin ETF maybe
in 2024 but I'm not optimistic for 2023
I think the question investors should
ask themselves is if you are optimistic
that will get there in 24 or 25 do you
want to wait or do you want to allocate
now uh we think a lot of investors want
to allocate ahead of that
um but yeah I think we'll get there but
I don't think it'll be this year I think
it's just a difficult regulatory
environment for them I don't know how
much you can comment but obviously
grayscale is uh locked in this lawsuit
with the SEC Are there specific things
that you all are looking for as this
plays out whether it is a specific
arguments from grayscale or responses
from the SEC
um how do you kind of think about you
know what's important there versus maybe
what's noise and we'll get reported but
people could ignore and not really put
too much weight on yeah I mean I should
say grayskill is of course both the
competitor and a friend uh we're all
friendly in this crypto ecosystem we're
rooting for them in this lawsuit what
they're really trying to pin the SEC
down on is the fact that the SEC has
approved Bitcoin Futures ETFs which
settle to the spot price of Bitcoin and
then in the spot applications they're
saying you can't rely on that price
because it's subject to Market
manipulation and uh you know I studied
philosophy in school I don't know how
you can hold those two arguments at the
same time and so I'm really hopeful that
they win this case the important thing
for investors to realize is that doesn't
necessarily mean that the SEC approves
spot Bitcoin ETFs the market
manipulation standard is just one piece
of the puzzle in getting a spot Bitcoin
ETF approved and I suspect uh if they
win the lawsuit uh we'll have to deal
with the other pieces the good thing
about those other pieces is I think
they're Solutions but they're not super
clean shots on goals that's why I think
it'll be 2024. so we're watching to see
like the rest of the industry does
grayscale win they had a very good day
in court it seemed like the judges
um asked tough questions of the SEC but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they'll win I do hope they win I think
their argument is sound I think they
should win
um but we'll see in the next few months
that makes sense I want to switch gears
a little bit and talk about the macro
environment uh obviously we have seen uh
immense inflation in the United States
uh ended up hitting nine percent or so
uh we then saw the FED step in they
rapidly raised interest rates they
conducted quantitative tightening uh and
although they did all of that before the
balance sheet started to expand again uh
we only got inflation down to six
percent according to the official CPI
metric at the same time that they were
raising rates and they were conducting
all that quantitative tightening Bitcoin
dropped all the way to about fifteen
thousand dollars it now sits almost at
thirty thousand somewhere in that twenty
eight thousand twenty nine thousand uh
dollar range as we record this
um is there something to be said about
the fact that Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies and we can just use
Bitcoin as kind of the proxy for for the
whole space and the price action
all of this quantitative tightening all
of these interest rate raises and we're
still sitting around thirty thousand
dollars kind of you know half or about
40 percent of where we were at the
all-time high is that a strong signal
for the industry
I think it's an exceptionally strong
signal for the industry
um you know it's it's like it's like a
rope-a-dope boxing match you have all
that quantitative tightening you know
the regulatory pressures you had all the
blow-ups last year you had FTX
it would be hard to design a world that
was more challenging to crypto than what
we've lived through for the last 12
months just look at my hair it's like
all turning white
um and yet we're at thirty thousand
dollars uh you know thirty thousand
dollars or near thirty thousand dollars
is well above the 2017 highs it's nearly
10x where we were at the bottom of the
2018 lows it shows that this industry is
moving in the right direction it's here
to stay uh again I'll go back to the
thing I said earlier there's all this
short-term negative news the long-term
news is really positive right even from
a traditional Financial ecosystem we now
have Fidelity offering uh crypto trading
to retail investors we have Bank of New
York custody we're trying to move into
cup design crypto NASDAQ just said it
wants to move into the long-term news is
really good and crypto investors should
feel confident that cycle over cycle
we're doing great I think it's looking
like this will be the next big bull
market cycle I think we'll move to New
all-time highs we should feel very
confident about where we are we're in a
really strong position
you all recently launched a new fund uh
it has this
Optimum rolling methodology and I'm
already outside of my circle of
competence in in uh what the fun does
and how it works so maybe you could just
start from the basics of like what is
this kind of rolling methodology and why
is it uh potentially a more beneficial
uh exposure uh kind of approach for
investors than maybe some of the other
vehicles that you guys offer sure
absolutely yeah it's a Bitcoin Futures
ETF the ticker's bitc you know the way
Futures work is that a Futures exchange
like this the CME will offer you the
ability to buy Bitcoin at a particular
price every month for let's say the next
12 months they actually extend longer
than that but you could enter into a
contract to buy it at the end of April
to buy it at the end of May to buy it at
the end of June to buy it at the end of
July Etc
the way the first generation of Bitcoin
Futures ETFs work is they just buy the
next month so right now they'd be
invested primarily in the April contract
and then when the April contract expires
when we get to April 30th they buy May
and then they buy June what our strategy
does is it said instead of doing that
let's look at all the available
contracts and decide using some
relatively complex math which one is
best positioned which one is on sale and
which one is charging a premium
sometimes it'll be that front month
contract in which case our ETF will look
like every other ETF but sometimes
December's contract will be priced at a
nice discount and will buy the December
contract if you look at other ETFs as
you know I come from the ETF industry in
virtually every commodity you have both
types of ETFs so there's a front month
oils ETF and then there's an optimized
role oil ETF and what you see is that
short-term Traders like the front month
contract it's more liquid response to
spot prices and long-term investors like
the optimized role strategy this has
been
in Academia in the commodity space for
30 years it's not a new idea we're just
applying it to bitcoin because we serve
long-term investors look if you want to
trade Bitcoin for the next week this is
not the fun for you but if you want to
allocate for the next year or two years
or three years five years we think it
may be a better strategy for many
investors
when you look at that and given who your
investors are in terms of a lot of these
Ras and institutions are they splitting
let's just take Bitcoin as an asset
their exposure well they say hey look I
want some direct you know spot price
exposure I actually want some you know
front month Futures exposure and then
actually I do want some of this uh kind
of rolling methodology as well or do you
tend to see them just pick one exposure
kind of strategy and just stick with
that and kind of have that concentration
uh to get exposure to any one of the
assets you offer yeah most most
investors just choose one strategy uh
I'm gonna I'm gonna head this way we see
some that split in between crypto stocks
and we offer crypto stock ETF and direct
exposure so they say I want some Bitcoin
and I want some miners to give you an
example
um but a lot of people just want their
crypto allocation they want to be sure
it's safe they want to be sure it's
managed by a professional firm that's
expert in crypto and then they move on
with their day right we think about
crypto 24 7 365 but again these are busy
folks they think about crypto
seven minutes a week and they just want
a solution that's really simple safe and
secure and that's what we try to offer
how much of that interest is coming from
their clients kind of pushing them and
saying Hey I want this figure it out
versus them saying hey this is an
interesting asset class and let me go
get my clients into it and I'll have to
do some education of the clients yeah
great question it's about 80 client
pushed right I mean remember coinbase
has more users than TD Ameritrade
Charles Schwab E-Trade and interactive
brokers the big four retail Brokers
combined
retail investors are allocating to
crypto and if you're a financial advisor
and you're responsible for the wealth of
a family do you want them investing in
crypto on their own selling at the wrong
time buying at the wrong time putting
assets on FTX doing who knows what or do
you want them to uh be guided by you now
there are a lot of retail investors who
are well positioned to manage their own
Investments and they typically manage
their stock Investments and their crypto
Investments and they manage their 401ks
and they're very sophisticated but there
are other investors who don't want to
think about their Investments right they
have a car dealership and they hire
someone else to worry about that stuff
those people shouldn't be investing in
crypto on their own they'll be better
off with a professional investor helping
them and that's the market that we serve
right both both are great but if you're
if you're going to manage your
Investments yourself you have to be
serious about it some people want to
some people don't if you don't you
should have that guy your advisor manage
your stocks and your crypto and
everything else all together when you
all think about building the firm one of
the things that's very interesting is
you're building an asset management firm
and yes it is very much I would call
Tech enabled or kind of built on these
technology rails but the main difference
is not building an asset management firm
is the Assets in which you are
allocating the capital to what is some
of the lessons learned over the last
couple of years uh in terms of building
an asset management firm touching these
new assets but still trying to you know
adhere to best principles and building
Asset Management firms and risk
management regulation and compliance and
like all the fun stuff that every Ria an
Institutional Investor says Hey whether
I like it or not I gotta do it in order
to have a firm that lasts yeah
absolutely you know we've been
frustrated a little bit a bit wise we're
like the world's most conservative
crypto asset manager right we only work
with qualified custodians we screen out
a huge number of assets right now we
don't do things like stake our assets uh
we haven't explored some of the riskier
corners of crypto we didn't have
exposures to things like Luna or lending
through Celsius or other things like
that and um at times during bull markets
that can feel hard you see other people
doing that and having success uh and you
feel held back but what we found you
know we've been in the market for five
years which is a long time in crypto uh
is that this conservative approach has
paid off so being Security First
Regulatory Compliance first doing things
in the right way has long-term benefits
I think that's why bitwise has been here
for five years I think it's why we'll be
here for 50. and I think he made a good
point there are a lot of good lessons in
the traditional Financial World there
are reasons why people custody assets in
a certain way why they have compliance
regimes why they talk to investors in a
certain way we can import those into
crypto and that's what bitwise tries to
do we try to be both crypto native and
rooted in traditional investment finance
and I think it's it's paid off so far
you mentioned earlier your experience in
the ETF world uh many people on the team
are very well known to the traditional
Financial world uh I think maybe four or
five years ago uh there was a lot of
like hey what are you all doing why are
you doing this uh you're gonna ruin your
career like all the things that people
uh you know now kind of assign to new
areas of innovation uh for the people
who maybe haven't spent the time to
learn Etc what are you all hearing now
right you talked a little bit about the
customer interactions but from your
peers or many of them now becoming more
interested are they still holding out
what are you seeing they're still
they're becoming more interested by the
day
um you know one thing that really
changed once we got through the 2018
bear Market is the level of interest of
people moving into the space uh continue
to increase so we have really incredible
people from traditional Finance people
with 10 20 years of wholesaling
experience or trading experience who are
coming into bitwise from firms that
range from you know Vanguard to
Blackrock to Deutsche Bank uh to Goldman
Sachs they still want to move into this
space I think the biggest thing that's
changed in crypto since I got in full
time with bitwise you know five plus
years ago is people realize it's not
going away and I know that seems obvious
to us inside this industry but if you
back up five years ago the idea that
Bitcoin would go to zero was very alive
it was talked about in the industry it
was probably even conventional wisdom
and I really think that's not true
anymore right now you have investment
Banks writing research reports on it you
have JP Morgan writing research reports
on it it's part of the ecosystem their
prices on CNBC that's a sea change and
what that means is yeah we don't get
that same level of sort of uh disrespect
are you crazy that maybe we got five
years ago now it's like interesting tell
me more about it
we see a huge rise in artificial
intelligence and to those who have been
around a long time in crypto it feels
like you know everyone was looking over
at crypto then they go and they look at
AI maybe the next thing will be who
knows what
um but every single time that attention
kind of shifts between these different
Innovations with these different
Technologies it does seem like there is
a net gain and you can see some of that
in the price of these assets but also it
feels like there are a lot of companies
that are starting to just realize hey
this is technology this is actually not
nearly as new as people I think
previously assigned to it does that help
in recruiting efforts or other types of
kind of business activities that aren't
directly attributed to just you as the
CIO and and kind of the investment
decisions or the funds that you guys
offer yeah I think it opened people
opens people's minds we're living in a
disruptive age of Technology it's the
most exciting time that I've experienced
um certainly things like AI sort of take
away attention but I think the fact that
crypto's been here for so many years
you're starting to see so many different
applications that are real world
applications I think all of that is
additive I do think people know that
we're really going through a phase shift
in technology sort of akin to the phase
shift we went through in the internet
era where the market the world is
changing and so more people want to be
on the right side of that some of those
people will migrate directly to AI some
are migrating into crypto but they
realize that this change is coming and
so it is helpful to recruiting
um it's helpful to retention people
really want to work in this industry and
rightly so
what are the biggest risks that you see
for the industry moving forward right
obviously given the last 12 months or so
there's a whole bunch of things that
blew up failed didn't work uh and I
think now people are asking the question
rightfully so like okay well what are
the other risks what are the things that
I should start trying to mitigate now if
I want to be a player in the space over
the long run that has sustainable uh
kind of power and and has a bright
future in front of them what are the
risks that you all see yeah I mean look
in the US you have to talk first about
regulatory risk uh I'm a very optimistic
guy I generally think even things like
coinbase SEC is going to be net positive
for the industry but that's a
probabilistic view uh there's a 30 case
where that's negative for the industry
and there is a concerted effort in the
U.S to crack down on crypto to limit
crypto and as a result you could see
really harmful regulations pop up that
would hamstring this industry in the US
and force it abroad so I think that is a
real concern
um I do think you know the banking
ecosystem uh while we have additional
Banks to replace uh silvergate with
signature we don't yet have systems to
replace uh Signet uh and the silvergate
exchange Network which really did make
the crypto industry more efficient and
so I think there's a little bit of
inefficiency
um that I worry about and then you know
I do think we need to see the real world
applications gain traction uh we need
improvements in ux ETC but if there's a
big worry it has to be regulatory if
you're not thinking about that if you're
being Pollyanna and assume it will all
work out it doesn't always all work out
I think it will work out but it's
something we think about actively every
day if it was talking about jurisdiction
so if regulation is one of the big risks
or one of the big kind of focuses of how
you navigate that obviously we're we
spent a lot of time talking about the
United States you and I both live in the
U.S that's where our businesses are
based uh that's where a lot of the
investors that are interested in these
assets and users of bitwise are but
there are many other jurisdictions
globally and so how do you all look at
either servicing those uh jurisdictions
working within them or maybe employing
people just talk to me kind of
international markets outside the U.S
yeah we are a U.S Focus firm we serve us
investors but we think about the global
markets we have an ETF in Switzerland we
have a partner at ETF in Australia uh
we're always exploring other options you
know as difficult as the regulatory
environment is here uh you have blinders
on if you're not paying attention to
what's happening in Asia uh Asia is
reopening to crypto in really important
ways I think Europe is a very exciting
market right now uh the UK is a very
exciting market right now and of course
Switzerland's been favorable to crypto
for a long time what that means that
bitwise is we're open to and always
considering International opportunities
we'll do those opportunistically but the
core of our business is focused here in
the US right it's still uh an enormous
Market the largest market in the world
and over the long term I'm often Mystic
it will get crypto right uh it just
seems like we have to try everything
else before we get there
what are you most looking forward to
over the next 12 months obviously we
could talk about risks all day but
there's also exciting things is there
one big milestone or kind of two or
three achievements for the industry that
you're really looking forward to
yeah oh wow great question uh I'm really
excited about what's going on in uh in
the ethereum ecosystem and particularly
eip4844 and how it will quash costs on
Layer Two Solutions I think people don't
understand how important that is uh they
don't understand the value of a prices
that's effectively zero right if you
think about the cost of crypto
transactions it's gone from a few
dollars on average with spikes into the
hundreds to a handful of 20 cents 10
cents it's going to be sub Penny by the
end of this year his ethereum executes
on its uh road map and the applications
that open up at subpenny that aren't
open at 10 or 20 cents per transaction
are really enormous and I know that
sounds very theoretical uh but I think
it's a a game changer so I'm really
excited
um about that and more broadly I'm just
excited to see animal spirits returning
to crypto right we are in a bull market
it's funny you go out to investors and
they still sort of have this bear Market
mentality crypto's the best forming
asset class in the world this year I
think is that Steve saying we're going
to see some of those Animal Spirits
return to the space so ethereum and the
road map there the broader Bull
marketing crypto and how that will
change uh I think this will be a very
exciting year but I think the next three
years are going to be phenomenal in
crypto
what is your pitch to uh to investors in
terms of why they should take the time
to learn about the space learn about the
assets and potentially go ahead and
allocate to it when you talk today I'm
assuming it's some similar but some
different than it maybe was five six
years ago what does that look like today
yeah you know I think they're really two
pitches uh one is from a traditional
investment perspective crypto is if you
remove crypto from the name it's one of
the most attractive Assets in the world
it's the best performing asset class
over the last 10 years it has huge
potential upside it typically has very
low correlations and it's liquid I don't
want to go all CFA on you but High
returns low correlations and liquidity
is like a Magic Trinity and crypto has
all those three things so from an asset
allocation perspective it's this
beautiful thing the other thing I like
to point out is that crypto is still so
small
they're individual companies that are
larger this than this entire industry
it's still so early why do we talk about
it so much why are there 35 pages in the
president's economic report focused on
crypto why is it one of the primary
things that the SEC why are Venture
capitalists invested in because people
recognize that it could be 10 20 more
times bigger than it is today that it
has that level of disruptive potential
but it's still really small it's still
really early and people just have
Vanishing numbers of opportunities the
average investor never gets the chance
to invest in something that could be so
big so early right it's really hard to
access that opportunity so that doesn't
mean you put 100 of your wealth in it
but it might mean you put one to five
percent of your wealth I think it's a
really exciting story so those are two
different angles depends on the investor
but I think they're both right
I think that you are very convincing you
guys have done a great job building
bitwise you work with I think now 14
1500 rias have a ton of institutional
investors and so uh regardless of what
people say about the industry or the
assets I think that you all are one of
The Shining examples of kind of hard
work over a long period of time trying
to do things in a regulated kind of Safe
Way seems to be working so congrats on
all the success where can we send people
to find out more about bitwise about the
new fund or find you on the internet
yeah sure come on over to bitwise
investments.com you can access our
resources there or or just find me on
Twitter Matt underscore Hogan Hogan is
h-o-u-g-a-n it's got a funny u in it uh
but I'd love to see you there Matt thank
you so much I appreciate it you guys are
doing a fantastic job and we'll talk
soon
thanks for having me